c'est par une petite porte située à
l'arrière du bâtiment que les
malfaiteurs une demi douzaine
d'individus ont pu pénétrer dans la zone
de stockage et d'usinage de l'entreprise
après avoir visiblement neutraliser la
vidéosurveillance le timing était
parfait la société de gardiennage venait
de quitter les lieux les salariés
venaient d'arriver et d'ouvrir les
coffres l'or en barre plus de 12 kg
selon nos sources plus de 20 selon
d'autres étaient à portée de main pour
les salariés le choc est énorme
les gars savaient où ils allaient
comment faire il y a sûrement eu un gros
repérage en amont
je ne pense pas que ça vienne de
l'intérieur pour moi c'est du grand
banditisme
les six salariés présents au moment des
faits n'ont pu qu'obtempérer face à des
hommes lourdement armés de fusils à
pompe gourmands les braqueurs ont tenté
de forcer un coffre encore verrouillé
avant de finalement prendre la fuite
leur otage tous indemnes ont été
entendus dans la matinée tandis que les
experts de la scientifique passait de
longues heures à collecter le moindre
indice la direction quant à elle préfère
rester muette
donc aujourd'hui personne ne travaille
connu des grands noms de la place
vendôme l'entreprise qui fabrique bijoux
des accessoires de luxe cultivé la
discrétion ni panneau ni enseigne le
voisinage est le premier surpris par ce
spectaculaire fait divers vous saviez
qu'il y avait autant de quantités de
métaux précieux dans cette entreprise
rien du tout non simplement des fois on
voit le camion blindé venir certainement
pas pour rien
les malfrats non plus ne sont pas venus
pour rien le kilo d'or s'échange
actuellement à plus de 37000 euros
le parquet de besançon s'est dessaisi de
l'affairé au profit de la juridiction
interrégionale de nancy spécialisée dans
la criminalité organisée